hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers dawn who was in the
early stages of setting up a new
business he says he's not on Facebook or
Twitter but he wanted to get my advice
he's in a medical sales rep company that
he wants to create and he wanted my
advice on how to find new products to be
able to sell and hopefully be successful
with this new company so don I don't
know much about the medical sales
business but the best option for you is
to go and start talking to customers
most people will work the other way
around they'll go start talking to
suppliers and find great deals on new
products that they can sell only to find
out that customers don't want what
they're selling so your best bet is to
go find a customer start asking them
where they have a need so figure out
what they're trying to buy right now
that they're having a hard time buying
or if they have any problem
relationships with current suppliers all
right if somebody has a really good
relationship with the supplier and
they've been working with them for years
and really happy it's gonna be really
hard for you to get in there and be the
new guy but if they've had a bad
relationship or they're frustrated with
the supplier because you know they're
not delivering on time or a whole host
of other issues then that's an
opportunity for you to come in and be
able to be the new supplier so start
talking to customers find a pain point
that they have find the need and then
you're working around a paying customer
which is the best way to grow a business
if you can so it's exciting part for you
right now in this early stage I would
start talking to customers find that
pain point build around what they need
and you're on your way to building a
successful company so I hope that helps
dawn if you guys like this video please
give it a thumbs up below and I'll make
more and it also love to hear what your
thoughts are if you want to leave a
comment under this video and stay tuned
to the next episode
you